el norte de atenas se despertó en medio
del humo a unos 30 kilómetros al norte
de la capital griega
marín pump y no fue inmune a la ola de
incendios que golpea el oriente de la
región mediterránea al principal
responsable la peor ola de calor jamás
registrada en más de tres décadas desde
hace una semana territorios alrededor
del mediteráneo se han visto afectados
por violentos incendios difíciles de
controlar el 'top lo que ven sucedió en
apenas media hora
hay daños inmensos las casas fueron
quemadas fortunas enteras se fueron en
las llamas pero usted es el primer
ministro griego kyriakos mitsotakis se
desplazó hacia el pueblo de varín pompi
el más afectado por el fuego
las casas serán reconstruidas y el
bosque regresará sin embargo algunos
desafíos nos esperan aún tenemos algunos
días de calor intenso y de vientos por
esto le pedimos a cada uno de estar
alerta
en el país vecino de albania los
incendios cobraron la vida de una
persona mientras centenares de bomberos
y militares luchan por contener las
llamas en turquía desde hace una semana
los bomberos trabajan para controlar
varios incendios dos hidroaviones
españoles fueron despachados de
emergencia para ayudar en las labores
pero aún así miles de hectáreas
continúan en llamas y hasta el momento
ocho personas perdieron la vida en
italia los bomberos continúan con las
labores para contener las llamas de
algunos de los 800 focos que iniciaron
de manera simultánea durante el fin de
semana